I'm Dan Souza from cook science at
America's Test Kitchen and today we're
gonna make a kale salad that's a little
bit less bitter than normal with a
vinaigrette that stays together for a
really long time so the key to a good
vinaigrette is having it to stay
together not break you wanted to be
fully emulsified so the water and the
oil are mixed together it's nice and
smooth and creamy and it dresses your
green perfectly a problem with a lot of
immigrants is that they easily break
apart right after mixing so what we're
gonna do today is a make-ahead
vinaigrette that once it's emulsified
it'll stay that way in the fridge for a
full week let's get started we use a
couple of tricks we use mayonnaise which
has a powerful multiplier called
lecithin in it so that's very helpful to
keep it together we also use a little
bit of Dijon mustard and that helps hold
it together as well but the real secret
to a long-lasting vinaigrette this is
emulsified a long time is a little bit
of molasses molasses contains these
colorful pigments called the melanoidins
that are really large molecules what
they do is they slow down the movement
of liquid so we know that molasses is
very viscous it adds that viscosity to
the vinaigrette so our water and fat
phases are less likely to separate so
with our make-ahead vinaigrette you can
make it throw it in your fridge in a
week later it's still in multiply so we
all know that kale would be a little bit
too bitter sometimes so we're gonna
reverse the order of operations we're
going to massage it cut it and then
rinse it and we're gonna rinse off a lot
of those bitter compounds so for the
kale itself we realized that kale leaves
don't have a lot of flavor until they're
damaged in some way so in an undamaged
kale week you have an enzyme called
neuro sanae's and that is separated from
a sulfur containing organic compound
called the glucosinolate now when a kale
leaf is damaged by cutting or chewing or
by massaging they are allowed to
interact they form a new compound called
isothiocyanate and that is the bitter
compound that can make a little bit
tough
take and usually solution is to
overdress a kale salad cover Caesar
dressing you kind of lose the benefit of
the flavor of the kale and also the
health benefits so what we figured out
with cook science was that if we reverse
the order of operations when we're
prepping our kale so instead of washing
it and then massaging it chopping it
with massage and chop and then we rinse
it off we can wash away some of those
bitter compounds so we have a more mild
kale it's also more tender so we can
dress it with less dressing just a
little bit of shape of arm on top
delicious